All right, so now we get to talk about science.
We get to talk about design. We get to talk about DNA.
We get to talk about, well, let's be honest, we get to talk about a lot of things
several of us probably don't have a ton of expertise in.
And then we talk about truth and logic and even what, you know, our faith is.
That's sort of, for most of us youth leaders, that's in our wheelhouse.
But when we get into things like science, it gets a little bit more tricky.
You don't have to be an expert in this space, but I want you to pay attention to a
couple of things and remember a couple of things as you work through these next
several weeks focusing on things like science.
Our students are taught, if you ask your students, if you go into the public school
classroom and you look inside of what their textbooks say and what teachers are
saying is this sort of separation between things of faith and things of
science. We're told that these things don't belong together.
I remember even back when I was in seventh grade many years ago, I was told by my
teacher when I looked up and I saw this chart of a monkey suddenly
becoming more and more evolving into a man, I remember looking at that going, how
can that be? I remember raising my hand and asking the question, saying, this
doesn't seem right. And I'll never forget what she said to me.
And it seemed to solve it for me.
And she said, I get what you're saying, but that is religion and faith.
And this is science. Even right there as a seventh grader, the
dichotomy, the split, the two separate spheres of life were defined
for me. So for our students, that really is what's happening a lot and a lot of
students are like, that's okay and they're comfortable with that.
That's fine. But the more we research, the more technologically advanced we
become, the more STEM research and STEM like subjects and
careers become more popular and much more pursued by our
students post-college, the more this separation is going to get defined.
So it's crucially important that our students understand that, guess what?
These two things don't actually need to be separated.
In fact, the more we discover through science, the more we
actually are going to discover about God.
The more we discover how awesome He really is.
And over these next couple of weeks, you're actually going to start to see that.
So don't feel like you have to know all the science.
Don't run out to the library and get a bunch of science books and try to figure it
all out. I've tried it's it's unless that's your thing knock yourself out but for
most of us it's probably not a time thing we have nor maybe even the ability so
don't worry about that but focus on getting your students to see that these two
worlds actually interconnect and I might even suggest that find some of those
students who are really really like amped up about science and love of it, whether
it be math, whether it be even computer technology, anything in the biochemistry,
anything in the science world, and get them switched on here and now.
This is a great way to get some of those students engaged.
So for this first week, I think one of the crucial parts of your gathering is going
to be your storyteller. Really focus in on somebody who can connect science
and faith. So I would suggest either find a university professor, find somebody in
the science field, find somebody who actually does biology or chemistry
or some field in the sciences that is in your church congregation that can stand in
front of the students and say, here, this is how I connect these two things
together. This is how I can see God when I'm looking through a telescope or a
microscope. And this is how I can see God in the field of math or whatever it might
be. It's hard, and trust me, you're going to need to sit down and probably have a
conversation with the person that you'd like to do this and make sure that they can
comfortably make that connection.
I've even talked to Christian educators who are math teachers and English teachers
and science teachers who, even as their profession, have a really, really difficult
time sometimes making those connections.
I've done seminars with some teachers and helping them to, especially math teachers
for some reason, to help them make that connection so they can see their subject
matter through a biblical lens. So make sure you sit down with those people and help
them see it if they don't already see it, but make sure that they can deliver that
message to your students because this is a crucial moment.
If your students can see that from somebody else in your congregation who actually
does, some of the jobs that they might be pursuing down the road.
That's a huge, huge win for you as you move forward in this study.
So in addition to the questions that we've provided for you,
it would be a really, really good idea for you to talk specifically with your
students about some of the school subjects and some of the things that they're
actually learning in school. So whatever they happen to be learning at this
particular time in their curriculum, have them talk about that.
You might even have them bring in their textbooks, have them talk about what are the
things that they're learning so they can specifically tie in the subject matter that
they're dealing with in school and their Christian worldview so that you can help
them make those connections. Again, you don't have to know everything about that
particular subject. You guys can work through that together.
In fact, it's a great opportunity to have your students teach you about what they're
learning. It's going to help them learn it and then you could help them see the
biblical worldview behind it. So what we often forget is that in the school
world, and a lot of our professional worlds too, we have this thing called two
different aspects of our world. We have what's called the private sphere,
and we have what's called the public sphere.
This is important to get if you think of this as a house.
house, okay?
And this is your upstairs where your bedrooms are.
And what you think and what you do up in your bedrooms is your private business,
right? Not many other people are going to be up there.
But when you have people over for company or whatever, you have your public spheres.
This would be your kitchen, your living room with those kinds of things.
These are two different spheres of life.
And the things that you do here are not the same as what you do here oftentimes
the way we think is the exact same thing so what our students and sometimes us
what we'll do is we'll put our school or our jobs
um in our public life and we'll talk about some things specifically here but then
we'll put our Jesus life up in our private sphere and we separate these two
things and we don't want them to connect and we learn to live that way.
Just as I was taught in seventh grade, this is exactly what my teacher was telling
me to do. Separate these two things, live in a two-story home, and leave it that
way. But what we want to do is we want to get rid of this and put Jesus
down in our public space.
So here's the bottom line. Science doesn't actually contradict our faith.
Instead, it lays a crucial foundation for understanding our world.